Herr grupaller vielleicht die erste
Frage an Sie was hat sie heute mehr
überrascht oder beschäftigt
die Tatsache dass die ihre
Jugendorganisation die AFD
Jugendorganisation als gesichert
rechtsextrem eingestuft worden ist oder
die Idee einer Unternehmenssteuerreform
der
Ampel also da keines von dem beiden
Themen explizit wenn Sie jetzt auf die
Wirtschaft anspielen äh dann hat mich
interessiert sie nicht doch interessiert
sie ich kommen dazu her wir haben ja
Zeit äh mich hat eigentlich überrascht
die Aussage vom Finanzminister Herr
Linder und vom Wirtschaftsminister habg
dass Deutschland nicht mehr wir
konkurrenzfähig in im wirtschaftlichen
Bereich ist das hat mich schon als das
war im Prinzip ein ein Eingeständnis von
zwei Ministern ein Regierung sagen sie
ja auch immer da sind sie sich ja sehr
einig ja mittlerweile gibt geben uns die
Minister der Bundesregierung recht mit
diesem Kurs kann man dieses Land auch so
nur in die Wand fahren und zur
Einstufung der Jugendorganisation das
ist jetzt im everfahren wir klagen dort
weiter also auch das gilt's noch
abzuwarten Glauben nicht dass die
rechtsextrem sind oder anders gefragt
was ist die Begründung dafür ja die
Begründung äh das ist natürlich äh das
wird muss gerechtig geklärt werden das
Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz hat das
äh so für sich eingestuft wir klagen
dagegen auch gegen diese Begründung wir
erleben jaäh auf Landesebene wo Sachsen
ja auch äh so eingestuf wo uns das
Landesamt der Verfassungsschutz die
Begründung ja nicht einmal mitteilt also
wir wissen nicht mal konkret was uns
vorgeworfen wird und da ist es natürlich
schwierig zu reagieren aber das ist
natürlich auch wahltaktisch begründet es
liegen und stehen Landtagswahlen in
diesem Jahr an
damit will man natürlich eine starke
Opposition klein machen jetzt era auf
der Verfassungsschutz sagen sie
missbraucht oder wird politisch
missbraucht ja es ist eine
weisungsgebundene Behörde die von
Ministerin von Innenministern mit
Parteibuch natürlich Instruktion bekommt
also Entschuldigung warum wurde denn
Herr Masen
abgesetzt noch mal also über Maßen reden
wir jetzt gerade nicht doch wir reden
über Verfassungsschutz nee genau es geht
um die Frage ob der Verfassungsschutz
sozusagen politisch missbraucht wird ja
absolut aber warum ist den dann
Brandenburg nicht dabei und
SachsenAnhalt schon in Brandenburg wird
auch gewählt SachsenAnhalt nicht ja ich
denke in brandenbrüg wird als nächstes
kommen davon gehen wir fest aus dass
auch da genau das gleiche das Schema
wiedergreifen soll um in Wahl takaktisch
zu versuchen die Bürger da hingehend zu
beeinflussen aber es wird nicht gelingen
gerade in Ostdeutschland gelingt es
nicht mehr aber das heißt sie sagen sie
sind da wenn das so ist dann wären sie
ja ein
Opfer das ist dem zufolge deswegen
klagen wir ja auch sonst würden wir es
ja hinnehmen und noch dazu wenn ich
keine Begründung vom Verfassungsschutz
bekomme die kriegen sie ja noch ja
Entschuldigung man kann do nicht in die
Öffentlichkeit gehen eine Partei im
Prinzip eine Oppositionskraft so
anschwerzen und die Begründung nicht
geben dazu wenn wenn ich selber als
Parteichef auch Dinge abstellen soll und
möchte und ich die Begründung nicht
kenne woran soll ich dann arbeiten
erklären Sie mir das sie haben keine
Idee warum man die als gesichert
rechtsextrem einstuft richtig keine Idee
nein ist jemand wie börn höcke für Sie
rechtsextrem dann müssten wir mal
definieren was rechtsextrem eigentlich
ist ja könen wir gerne Anfang für mich
ist ist ein Extremist der mit Gewalt
oder mit mit Gewaltfantasien versucht
die freiheitlich demokratische
grundordung in Frage zu stellen oder
diese zu bekämpfen und das sehe ich bei
unseren Mitgliedern zumindestens bei den
aktuellen in die in unserer Partei
Arbeiten nicht und wenn es einer wenn
einer aus der Reihe tanzt dann wird er
auch diese Partei verlassen müssen das
ist die klare rote Linie wir sind
grundgesetzpartei für uns zählt das
Grundgesetz und auch die freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung also noch mal
björn höcke ist keiner der von sozusagen
umsturzfantasien oder völkische und so
weiter würden Sie sagen der ist raus der
ist nicht rechtsextrem ist für mich
nicht
rechtsextrem interessant Frau Clemens
für sie mir fallen da direkt Z ein paar
Aussagen ein beispielsweise in schnell
Roder als BN höcke über die
Fortpflanzung von Menschen Afrika sprach
als wärend Bakterien oder mir fällt da
die Rede ein im wie man Dresen
inzwischen sagt Brauhaus höcke als er
vom Denkmal der Schande sprach und
von V manmal der Schande Entschuldigung
genau oder mir fällt dann Siegbert Dröse
ein der auch auf dem aussichtsreichen
Listenplatz steht für die Europawahl
dassen Kreisverband Wahlkampf machte mit
Autos auf deren schildern unter anderem
ah 1818 standen oder GD Großdeutschland
3345 davon könnte ich jetzt ehrlich
gesagt relativ viele beispi haben diese
Beispiele haben wir ja schon Z mal 20
mal immer wieder wiederholt werden
deswegen ja nicht deswegen ist do für
mich eine Person nicht g deswegen gleich
rechtsextrem ich habe ihn doch gerade
die Definition von Rechtsextremismus die
im übrigen auch auf der Webseite für
politische Bildung genauso dargestellt
ist geschildert einzelne Aussagen und da
gibt's einige Politiker im übrigen auch
andere Parteien die sicherlich mal
daneben greifen die ich nicht
unterschreibe die es auch bei uns gibt
keine Frage und die ich auch zurückweise
und wo ich auch mit diesen Politiker ins
Gespräch gehe heißt es für mich noch
lange nicht dass diese Person
rechtsextremistisch ist Hans Georg mßen
ist im Prinzip auch jetzt als
Rechtsextremist eingestuft worden er
darf beobachtet werden vom
Verfassungsschutz die Frage muss man
doch natürlich und die Frage mus
wirklich stellen wird
beobachtet ja noch mal also der
Verfassungsschutz beobachtet sich schon
teilweise selbst die Frage ist wer hier
mittlerweile in diesem Land nicht
regierungskonform agiert ist mit wird
immer mehr als und wird immer häufiger
als Rechtsextremist eingestut ich weiß
es z.B nicht wie ich eingestuft bin über
mich werden auch Akten angelegt ich
finde es übrigens wirklich für eine
Demokratie im5 32 Jahr nach der
Wiedervereinigung abenteuerlich dass
Akten wieder von Menschen angelegt
werden ob mit staatlich Geldern mit von
staatlichen Institutionen von einem
Verfassungsschutz der im keinem anderen
Industriestaat
Europas so aktiv ist gegen die
Opposition wie in Deutschland ich glaube
nicht dass es in den aber Herr ker das
noch nie jemand Gewalt als Option ihrer
Partei gegen andere gesehen hätte das
lässt sich n wirklich schnell
wiederlegen egal ob wir jetzt zu Peter
bistron gehen zwei zweiter Platz auf der
europawahlliste der der gesagt der
gesagt hat dass man der gauland
zustimmte dass man die
exintegrationsministerin solche Menschen
entsorgen sollte und der in Südafrika
mit dort der rechtsextremruppen
schießüberen gemacht hat oder Menschen
die gesagt haben dass im Zweifel auch an
der deutschen Außengrenze Waffengewalt
zum Einsatz kommen sollte und sich GEG
gefüchuldig war gerade welche anderen
deutchen Politiker sag fallen mir jetzt
in dem Moment nicht ein aber
nichtsrotz sorry ich will in aller
Respekt mit allem Respekt aber wenn Sie
das so sagen müssen sie auch sagen wer
das ist ja gut dann Frau ich sie ist
dann Frau Zimmermann auch eine
extremistin wenn Sie uns als Haufens
Scheiße betitelt unsere wähle als haben
gerade Gewalt zum definitorischen
Element g komm no kommt noch weiter oder
wie Herr Söder uns als Partei
bezeichnet als Parasiten bezeichnet ich
meine was ist denn das sie bisschen von
dem gewaltargument Weg was sie vorher
aufgestellt hatten um Extremismus zu die
Frage ist die Frage ist ob man an der
deutschen Grenze mit schusszwaffengewalt
auch diese Grenze schützen kann ja oder
nein so und das lässt das Gesetz zu
Punkt so sollte man sollte man das
notfalls machen das sollte man natürlich
nicht nicht machen aber zumindestens
laut Rechtslage ist es zulässig also es
ist nicht rechtsextremistisch wenn man
von frtionsprecher mussten sie entlassen
weil er Menschen geflüchtete ver
deswegen haben genau deswegen haben
genau deswegen haben wir ihn entlassen
das ist richtig aber jetzt fen sagen Sie
mir noch mal sie bringen Zitate die
schon 10 Jahre alt sind die schon durch
x Talkshows gegangen sind wir auch
wollen sie das noch erwähnen das könnte
ich auch umgekehrt genauso fragen wie
oft die AFD noch solche Ausschreitungen
keung Aussagen mit den ich mich nicht
gemein mache die ich auch kritisiere
keine Frage aber das spricht nicht für
die Gesamtheit der Partei und das ein
Unterschied kommt ihn das nicht
eigentlich sogar gelegen oder warten Sie
vielleicht nicht sogar drauf selbst mal
als rechtsextrem betitelt zu werden ich
habe manchmal den Eindruck dass das in
Teilen ihrer Wählerschaft oder in Teilen
von Sympathisanten der AFD sogar ganz
gerne gesehen wird im Sinne des nur wer
noch rechtsextrem ist es eigentlich
gegen den Staat und ist eigentlich gegen
die herrschende Politik man hört es
immer wieder wird der Bürger unbequem
ist er sich rechtsextrem also wir
grereisen nich selber sehr auf diese
Begriffe und ich habe eben auch oft den
Eindruck dass wir dass sie bisschen ihre
Schlagkraft verlieren in dem Moment und
das sieht es ganz geschickt eigentlich
umkehren also war die Frage ist sie
haben es ja richtig gesagt die
Schlagkraft verlieren dahingehen dass
man mittlerweile pauschaltier pauschal
Menschen mit als als Extremisten
bezeichnet und überhaupt nicht mehr
unterscheiden auch nicht mer definiert
was das konkret ist un hat aber hier
keiner gemacht Herr kopaller ne ich bin
ich bin bei sie sagen wir müssen sauber
sauber hingucken ich finde auch z.B wir
müssen auch weil hier ein ein sehr
erfolgreicher Schriftsteller sitzt auch
mit der Sprache aufpassen bin ich völlig
bei und das was sie da gerade zitiert
haben was war das der Haufen Scheiße und
so weiter und die
parasitenfänger me könte auche Beispiele
nicht üinander sprechen richtig und ich
finde das sage ich ihn auch ganz offen
ich finde die Verrohung in der in der
aktuellen politischen Debatte in dieser
aufgeheizten Situation in Deutschland
von allen Parteien aber da haben sie ein
Anteil dran oder nicht ich habe ihn hab
es ja gerade gesagt von allen Parteien
finde ich nicht in Ordnung aber ich
finde das zumindestens ein
Bundespräsident
ähm gerade sie beziehen sich jetzt auf
den Rattenfänger auf den auf den
Rattenfänger als als Amt des
Bundespräsident dass der diese große
Verantwortung h hat dieses Land nicht
weiter zu spalten und zu einen auch zu
versuchen auch mit einer großen
Oppositionspartei die mittlerweile 20
55% im Osten noch mehr Wähler hinter
sich schart und das sind eben 10 12
Millionen Wähler und wie will man damit
ein Stück weit mundtot machen und das
wer ich nicht akzeptieren das ist das
ist wiederum das was sie insinuieren
auch beim Verfassungsschutz ich habe
damit ein echtes Problem ich ich finde
man muss sauber sein in der
sprachefassungschutz insoniert auch auch
genauso ist Behörde genauach dieörde ist
weisungb die ist weisunggeb das mag ja
trotzdem sein aber okay das heißt das
passt in dieses narrativ ich hab neich
ich wollte eigentlich gar nicht mit ihn
darüber reden aber neulich ihre kchefin
Alis Weidel im Bundestag die der
Bundesregierung vorwirft sie hassen
dieses Land würden sie auch so sehen ja
zumindestens liebt sie dieses Land nicht
so wie die bundregierung so wie die
Bundesregierung
agier das ist sicherlich Überspitzung
einiger Aussagen finden Sie das gut wenn
man so redet wenn Sie das so in diesem
Moment empfindet und das war sicherlich
eine Empfindung von Frau Weidel ja es
war sehr war sehr Z war aufgeschrieben
das war sehr bewusst vorgetragen auch
sehr sehr sehr mit Emphase das war
völlig klar Entscheidung die ich sehe
und wie die politische Regierung oder
die Regierung aktuell agiert ja ich kann
man das sagen und sehen dass dieses Land
aktuell von Politikern regiert wird die
mit Deutschland wenig am Hut haben die
nicht die deutschen interess anderes das
ist das ist immer das
interessante sie reden immer so dass man
sie eigentlich an dem Punkt nicht so
wirklich festnageln kann die Aufgabe
eines Politik dass man mich nicht
festnagelt ja ja ja bitte bitte nicht
jetzt nicht jetzt irendwie nicht
festlegen ich meine jeder Politiker
jeder Moderator auch hat doch ein eigen
Stil ja und mein Stil ist ein anderer
von Frau Weidel mein Stil ist ein
anderer von mein sie ist ein anderer von
Herrn Brandner von etlichen and ich weiß
es gibt Menschen in dieser Sendung hier
die reden viel extremer als sie
beispielsweise jemand wie wie Herr
eiwanger z.B redet sehr viel direkter
und viel extremer als sie das tun und
noch mal finde das gut wenn man die
Sprache sozusagen im Blick hat deswegen
noch mal die Frage wenn sie da sagt da
gibt es diese bundesregier
ja
mensindw die sind gewählt demokch die
haben ein Eid geschworen auf dieses Land
ja und dann sagt man unterstellt die
hassen dieses Land das ist finden sie
das gut ich finde das ist noch im Rahmen
dessen was sagbar ist in keinsterweise
finde ich das problematisch oder mir
geht Kal den Rücken runter soll ich ih
sagen warum wissen sie laufen bei
anderen reden auch vom Bundes kannst
läuft auch mehr kalten Rücken um wie wir
als Partei wür niemals zu ihnen sagen
sie dieses Land aber natürlich das wird
auch von uns behauptet dass wir das
landede von der Bundesregierung ja ich
suche nach ich wir können gerne mal den
Faktencheck machen welche Aussagen es da
gibt noch mal jeder Politiker hat seinen
eigenen Stil und ich finde ist aber
keine Stilfrage mehr doch es ist von der
freiheitlich demokratischen grü und auch
von der Meinungsfreiheit vor allem ist
ist gedeckt Herr L das ist pun das ist
noch mal was anderes mir geht mir geht z
anderen Punkt ich würde gerne Klaus Ruh
Matzen in die Runde holen der als
Politiker n auch Sprache auf die Sprache
achten muss lange Bürgermeister in
Rostock war der also auch den Aufstieg
der AFD sozusagen mit Sicherheit aus
nächster Nähe beobachtet und gesehen hat
ich habe vor ziemlich genau 10 Jahren
stand ich vor einem Mann in Texas
äh und im Hintergrund drehte sich so ein
so ein so so ein bohturm da ja da wur
der Öl gefördert und so weiter und ich
fragte ihn nach der Situation in Amerika
es war 2016 kurz vor der Wahl von Trump
und der sagte da sitzt im Weißen Haus
ein Mann und er hat den Namen nicht aus
gesprochen Obama der hasst dieses Land
und deswegen geht's mir da kalten Rücken
runter weil ich denke so hat's dort
angefangen diese Art zu reden das sind
diese Codes das ist diese Sprache von
der ich immer denke nee so sollten wir
nicht miteinander reden wie sehen Sie
das also erst einmal will ich festhalten
dass ich glaube dass es zwei Aspekte hat
die hier sehr gefährlich sind auf die
eine Seite würde ich einfach mal sagen
egal was jemand von der Bundesregierung
hält die stehen nicht morgens auf und
überleg sich wie können wir heute die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger von Deutschland
ärgern ich glaube die stehen schon auf
um den bestmöglichen Job zu machen und
warum finde ich das gefährlich ich bin
Wirtschaftsminister was wir hier gerade
tun ist ja auch ein Bild von Deutschland
darzustellen Deutschland wie man das im
Ausland wahrnimmt wenn ein externer
Investor zu uns kommen muss und eine
solche Debatte mitbekommt wie wir über
unsere Bundesregierung über unsere
Verfassungsschutz reden ich glaube da
würde ich mir schon Sorgen machen ob ich
dann bereit wäre in diesem Land zu
investieren riesigen Problem erstens
zweitens wir kämpfen um kluge Köpfe und
fleißige Hände die nach Deutschland
kommen sollen auch hier stehen wir im
internationalen Wettbewerb mit solchen
Auseinandersetzungen und ich sage auch
mal rassistische Bemerkungen werden wir
mit Sicherheit nicht nach vorne kommen
und wir brauchen diese Menschen in
unseren Land und deswegen macht mir das
Sorge und da würde ich mir natürlich
wünschen dass man auch sich von sowas
distanziert dass man von sich aus sagt
das ist eine Aussage die sollte man so
nicht tätigen
das wä mal eine Frage um das Thema auch
abzuschließen weil wir wollen eigentlich
dann über Wirtschaft sprechen her
kopaller ist es das was Franziska meint
wenn sie sagt sie legen sich da nie so
genau fest und sie machen diesen
Spagat der sie irgendwann möglicherweise
auch zerreißen könnte diesen Spagat
zwischen den sozusagen eher gemäßigten
Menschen die anders sprechen in ihrer
Partei und die gibt es kenne ich auch
einige sehr viele sogar
und jemanden wie höcke oder auch Maxim
an K und anderen der jetzt zur
Europawahl antritt die genauso reden
nein ich will ja mal auf einige Aussagen
die sie zitiert haben auch von Herrn
Höcker auch von Herrn gaudern die sich
bereits von diesen Aussagen ja auch
zitiert distanziert haben aber das wird
ja überhaupt nicht zur Kenntnis genommen
man wiederholt sie in Monstranz
mittlerweile haben wir bei vielen Dingen
wenn ich an das denk mal der Schande
denke an diese Aussage wo sich Herr
höcke selbst distanziert hat haben wir
mittlerweile so ein Bart und in jeder
Sendung bringen sie das immer wieder
weil man das weil das natürlich immer
schön ist um das immer wieder
hochzukomen doch Quatsch nein das ist
nicht Quatsch ist nicht dass er sich
davon distanziert das
auch ganz klar gemacht dass er das so
nicht mehr sagen würde ich weiß nicht
wann aber er hat es getan getan ja warum
nehmen zur Kenntnis sehen Sie sie fragen
sich alle getan aber vielleicht sollten
Sie ihn auch mal einladen und ihn
diesbezüglich Fragen wissen Sie ich soll
mich jetzt von permanent anderen
Politikern
distanzierenfer das ist nicht meine
Aufgabe mich von permanent anderen
Politikern von Aussagen zu distanzieren
das wirklich ich kann mich nur von mich
selbst distanzi politier ihrer Partei
aber kann
doch nicht egal se was die sagen nein
ich habe ich würde ja nicht sagen dass
ich das unterschreibe und dass ich das
gut finde aber diese permanente sogar ja
und sicherlich sind da Aussagen dabei da
gebe ich Ihnen ja recht und auch wir
haben Fehler gemacht aber ich will noch
mal auf den gesamtpolitischen Komplex
zurückkommen auch auf die aktuelle
aufgeheilte Situation in diesem Land wir
haben es bei diesen Demonstration
aktuell gesehen wie hier agiert wird
welche Politiker auch der CDU mit
welchen Gruppierungen mit Extremisten
der antifah in görlit Herr kretch dort
auftritt die mir mein Haus anzünden
wollen mein Auto anzünden die mich
angreifen mit solchen Personen steht
Herr kretschman Glitz und demonstriert
gegen wen eigentlich gegen sich selbst
die Frage muss man doch mal beantworten
wo ist da die Distanzierung von diesen
politikerern von Extremismus also
umgekehrt her Kaller wurde ich genau
einmal auf einer Kundgebung gewirkt und
das war als bon höcke sprach in Dresen
2020 und ich ein Foto von Herrn Kalbitz
nicht löschen wollte es hat ein Ordner
mich mit meinem Schal gewirkt also tut
mir da gibt jz und ich wurde angegriffen
in ingstad und wurdeur wurde verletzt
muss mich zweimal operieren lassen das
ist alles unsälich gibt Behörden die das
Aufklären sollten und natürlich auch
diejenigen die sowas machen brauch wir g
nicht diskutieren dafür haben wir ein
Rechtsstaat müssen verurteilt werden da
gibt doch überhaupt keine zwei Meinung
sie haben natürlich total recht also das
geht in alle Richtungen und teilweise
ist das politische Klima so aufgeheizt
das ist mir auch schwer vorstellbar
erscheint teilweise wie kriegt man das
befriedet aber sie haben ja ein Anteil
daran als und deswegen kommen wir ja
immer wieder auf diese Sprachen und
diese Sprachregelungen zu sprechen weil
wir uns ja dann doch mal fragen
irgendjemand fängt damit an dann wird es
reproduziert dann landet das eben in all
diesen sie kennen es selbst in all
diesen sozialen Netzwerken und in den
telegramguppen und so weiter also sie
haben natürlich eine Vorbildwirkung als
Politiker als jemand der in der
Öffentlichkeit steht deswegen werden sie
immer wieder gefragt ich verstehe dass
sie genervt sind DAV ne ich bin nicht
genervt ich will sagen sie meinten sie
haben ein langen Bart teilweise von
lange warart mit den mit den Aussagen
die zum 10 15 mal immer wiederholt
werden wo ich m sage diesen x erklärt
worden die können wir in der nächsten
Sendung noch mal bringen und noch mal
bringen und noch mal bringen aber
deswegen werden sie immer wieder gefragt
damit sie sich dazu positionieren dit
das irg wir als Partei relativ zeitig
wurden relativ schnell in die
rechtsextreme in die faschistische Ecke
gestellt ja da gab's diese Aussagen noch
nicht mal also wir wurden doch relativ
zeitig schon ausgegrenzt in diesem
Bereich uns werden Positionen und Ämter
verwehrt ja wer grenzt denn aus wer die
sogenannten Demokraten wie sie sich ja
immer gern bezeichnen begrüßen uns im
Bundestag als nichtdemokr Partei wer
grenzt den aus ist das auch schon
Verrohung der Sprache oder ist das
einfach kann man das so hinnehmen wer
provoziert denn und ja es gibt bei uns
einige die sich provozieren lassen wir
müssen schon einmal kurz sagen es s
jetzt auch nicht nur alte Dinge sondern
die AFD legt schon auch g woll ich
gerade sagen genau das ist es ist jetzt
nicht mus ich muss ganz Ehrich sagen ich
finde schon dass wir die letzten Jahre
auch dazu gelernt haben dass wir uns
diszipliniert haben also ich denke das
ist auch der Anteil der beiden
Bundessprecher aktuell wir wirken da
sehr in die Partei rein das lasse ich
mir nicht einfach so nehmen und geben
dass meine Partei dort
genauso agiert wie noch V von den ersten
Jahren viele unserer Politiker waren
vorher keine Politiker kam aus den
normalen Leben ich ich selbst ja auch
aus dem mittelständischen
Wirtschaftsbereich wo ich herkomme und
ja es gibt Dinge die ich vielleicht im
wirklichen Leben anders sagen würde als
in der Politik wo man auch vorsichtiger
sein sollte g spezieller kraah war ja
vor schon Politiker war vor schon bei
der CDU jahreang sie waren ja auch in
der Jungen Union ne genau bei ihm kann
man nun glaube ich nicht sagen dass ist
alles versehenlich leisungen s sondern
ganz bewusst immer wieder nachlegt egal
ob KUB und Kit erzählt dass der einm der
Taliban in Kabul die einzig richtige
Antwort war auf den prideemth der
usbotschaft oder als ich in aber alle
mit so Aussage ist er doch noch nicht
Extremist ich s
nur wir hier auch schon mal gib gibt ja
auch Posts und Videos von dem Mann die
die also das würden sie so nicht sagen
Inter recht sie w auch einige Dinge
nicht sagen wie man sie sagt in ihrem
CDF nein ich und distanzieren sich auch
nicht von ich fin deswegen habe ich
vorhin gesagt es ist wir haben uns
gerade neulich letzte Woche knen Sie
auch überprüfen haben uns genau darüber
unterhalten die Frage wie reden wir auch
über die AFD wie geht man damit um ich
finde wenn man z.B über das Treffen da
in Potzdam spricht sousagen zu
insinuieren da war jetzt die AFD nein da
waren auch welche von der CDU mehr sogar
und ich ja ich weiß und ich ich deswegen
würde man aber nie auf die Idee kommen
zu sagen 400.000 CDU Mitglieder haben
irgendwelche komischen Pläne im Kopf
ganz im Gegenteil sondern es sind
Demokraten so wie man sie sich vorstellt
und ich würde auch nie auf die Idee
kommen zu sagen da war die
AFD hat man teilweise gemacht das gehört
ich will nur sagen das gehört gehört
alles mit dazu und das gehört auch dazu
zu sagen dass Frau Weidel ihren ihren
Büroleiter rausgeschmissen hat in dem
Zusammenhang sollte man nicht
unterschlagen und es ist we wei her
bitte nein ich wollte nur sagen und es
ist natürlich auch wichtig die
Unterscheidung zu machen dass wenn wir
über Extremismus sprechen und über
Rechte und vielleicht auch faschistische
aussagen dass da eben nicht automatisch
die Wähler und WählerInnen mitgemeint
sind also also wir sprechen und wenn wir
sie drauf festnageln in
Anführungsstrichen erstmal über sie als
Partei als Funktionär und innerhalb
dieser Partei auch eine gewisse
Machtstruktur sie machen das aber immer
ganz gut und tun dann so als würde man
als als würden die Medien und alle
anderen Parteien auch auch das das
Wahlvolk beschimpfen aber das ist nicht
der Fall das das würde auch niemanden in
in den Sinn kommen das was wir tun
können ist eben sie zu Rede zu stellen
und mal nachzufragen natürlich ja aber
aber verstehen sie das ist natürlich ein
eleganter Kniff den sie anwenden sie sie
sie nehmen das als ein Kritik nicht an
sich und vielleicht dann an ihren
Parteifunktionären sondern geben das
nach unten weiter und und schüren
dadurch auch diese Verschwörung des wir
gegen die und wir sind das Opfer und ihr
als als als wahlfolge als Bürgerin und
Bürger aber R so sehen es doch auch
viele Wähler dass sie gerade aufgrund
dessen eben nicht wahrgenommen werden
dass
gewählte Abgeordnete wie ich ich bin
zweimal direkt gewählt worden im im im
Wahlkreis Görlitz dass ich zuur
Veranstaltung nicht eingeladen werde
dass ich im Prinzip als einzige
Abgeordneter des Wahlkreises als
bundestagsabgeordnet damit überhaupt
nicht die Interessen des Wahlkreises und
damit der gewählten die mich gewählt
haben und ich vertrete auch die
Interessen die mich nicht gewählt haben
das nehme ich mir explizit auch als
Aufgabe dass ich auch für diese Politik
machen möchte ja die werden ausgegrenzt
und damit wird der Wähler ausgegrenzt
und das sehen viele ostdeutschen das
wissen sie die sehen das auch so da
können sie hin und her reden wie sie
wollen in diesem Bereich verstehe was
sie meinen aber ich sehe es doch bei der
berichterstatt zu Potzdam um darauf noch
mal zurückzukommen da wurde im heute
journal und in der tagesshow sofort
davon gesprochen dass es dort
deportationspläne gab also die beiden
hauptnachrichtensender und da war ich da
war ich geschockt Herr Lanz wo gab's da
die Distanzierung der beiden Sender da
hat man Worte reingebracht die an die
dunkelsten Zeiten erinnert hat das ist
eine Relativierung des
Nationalsozialismus und das haben die
öffentlichrechtlichen Medien mit
befeuert das muss man deutlich zu sagen
das haben wir auch hier in der Sendung
besprochen wir haben über die
Remigration gesprochen aber was
Remigration in dem Zusammenhang bedeutet
und was dort berichtet worden ist läuft
auf genau das hinaus was sie gerade
zitiert
habenftag was denn sonst nein also da
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen was ich
selber denke und tu Entschuldigung
Remigration heißt Rückführung in das
Land wo ich migriert bin lass uns dieses
das ist das ist der das ist das ist die
wahre aussageung da können sie be uns im
Programm nachlesen nichts anderes steht
da nichts anderes steht da niemand hat
davon gesprochen deutsche mit deutschen
Staats als deutsche Staatsbürger die
deutsche Staatsbürger sind mit oder ohne
migration Hintergrund auszuweisen
niemand hat davon
gesprochen da gibt's auch ganz andere
Aussagen auch zu dem Thema auch von
höcke auch in seinem Buch z.B nie
zweimal in den selben Fluss oder wie es
heißt ich rede V Parter das ver ich rede
aber von diesem Programm dort in in in
Potzdam und da waren ja wie wir gerade
festgestellt haben nicht nur sie und da
haben Menschen auf sehr ungute Weise
gesprochen würde sie gerne noch eine
Sache Fragen um um bevor wir gleich zur
zur Wirtschaft kommen sie haben gerade
gesagt ja sie waren woanders ne den
mörik den den den Zahnarzt
mit Frau wo sie dann im Prinzip mit
anfangen aber kennen Sie den ich kenne
viele zahnärz und wenn ich mir die
Gesundheitspolitik die
Gesundheitspolitik von der
la angucke dann ist es wichtig dass man
Zahnärzte auch kennt warum nicht kennen
Sie Herr mök den Rechtsextremen Zahnarzt
aus Düsseldorf Ken sie den was soll die
Debatte ich recht Wien aber kennen s den
oder nicht das steht das im nationalen
Interesse ob ich ihn kenne oder nicht
ist interessant das zu erfahren ehrlich
gesag ja das ist genauso uninteressant
zu fragen ob ich geimpft bin oder nicht
warum soll ich sowas beantworten auch
auch weil der man ein offenbar
rechtsextrem
hintergrundade und W früher mal irgendwo
war noch mal nicht früher selbst wenn
ich ih kennen würde
und nicht aus selbst wenn ich ih kennen
würde heißt es noch lange nicht dass ich
mit Aussagen oder mit sonstigen
Programmpunkten mich mit jeder Person
gemein mache ich kenne so viele Leute
ich kenne so viele Leute die mit mir ein
Gespräch führen wollen mit den ich auch
Gespräche führe die sich die sich mit
mir auch fotografieren lassen wollen des
deswegen ja ich kenne ihn deswegen
deswegen ma ich mir
lange ich Ei nicht rum nein aber ich
frage mich immer warum man sich immer
permanent rechtfertigen muss warum man
den oder den kennt was wollen sie damit
bezwecken ja man will damit ein Bild
spannen ich Ken nur gefragt ob sie ih
kennen weil ich einfach wissen wollte
welche Verbindung es da möglicherweise
seh sie Fang sie selber schon an in
diesem Bereich weiter zu fantasieren ob
Sie eventuell mögliche Möglichkeiten da
jetzt gehen sie in den Bereich der
Verschwörung genau
deswegen also mörig ist eine
interessante Figur weil das jemand ist
der ich glaube schon in Ende der 70er
Jahre bei den Kollegen der Zeit in einem
Artikel auftaucht als jemand der sehr
komische Dinge am äußersten re ganz kurz
ich bin noch nicht fertig und dann
taucht hat eine die AStA Vorsitzende
glaube ich da aus Düsseldorf junge
Historikerin dann noch mal weiter
recherchiert in der Landesbibliothek und
da findet sich dann auch ein Buch von
Herrn mörik äh indem er seine ganzen
völkischen Fantasien so ausbreitet also
die Frage ob Herr mörik rechtsextreme
Gedanken oder Fantasien hat oder nicht
die ist ehrlich gesagt sehr zweifelsfrei
beantwortet